Mohammed Ali says that for decades his
family has had a shop on Baghdad's our
Rashid Street now the store and all his
stock of sportswear have been destroyed
during anti-government protests these
were not demonstrators there were
saboteurs the ones who throw Molotov
bombs and attack our shops and heritage
are not demonstrators the ones who
destroy property throw stones use
catapults on not demonstrators there's
been a street here since the Ottoman
Empire paved it in 1910 it became a hub
of Baghdad's Catholic society
particularly during the Iraq oil boom of
the 1950s when it was lined with West
Rong's clubs and cinemas but because of
its strategic importance it was blocked
during the 2003 Iraq war and stayed
closed for 15 years it finally reopened
in January 2019 only to become a
battleground months later as protestors
fought with security forces concrete
barriers blocked roads the nearby Sanok
and knocked our bridges across the
Tigris were closed around 400 shops were
burnt this is the core of Iraq's economy
shop owners here have lost millions of
dollars and they've stopped us doing our
jobs for the last five months buildings
which have been renovated as part of a
regeneration project now like gutted and
empty the demonstrations have really had
an impact on the projects they've
stopped all repair work including
geological surveys and the assessment of
the traditional houses there we've
counted 32 houses either burned or
damaged the bridges are open again and
the barriers are being removed but
business is still slow al Jazeera was
here on the day in January 2019 when all
of our sheet Street reopened after 15
years businesses were telling us that
they were optimistic the trade was going
to be in
the government at the time was hoping
that this was going to send a message
that Iraq was safe again but after
months of protests business owners in
our Rashid Street say that they're weary
of hoping that just because cynic bridge
is reopened and these concrete bollards
are starting to come down the business
is going to get any better
Hussein Ali's sunglasses shop lies in
the shadow of those barriers we're to
empty the store and close it and came in
to check on the shops and one had been
drenched by fire hoses it had been
burned the whole area has been damaged
people still worried about coming over
the sunnat' bridge once again times are
hard for the shopkeepers evolved Rashid
straight Rob Mathison